[Music]
exoskeleton suits are often billed as a
way to give us puny humans Ironman
abilities hyeyeon die has simpler
ambitions for its line of power suits in
this case just to help weaklings like me
lift heavy objects with ease the car
maker says it also sees mobility as
going beyond vehicles engineers fitted
this suit hmx to a patient in Korea mr.
Yoon who was paralyzed from the waist
down after a paragliding accident it's
remarkably small and light it can be
worn over normal clothes and controlled
by buttons on the crutch handle a
patient leans forward and slightly away
from the leg that they want to move and
a motor in the suit does the rest the
battery lasts about four hours and top
speed is a kind of slow stroll at
one-and-a-half miles an hour
Honda is eyeing a market for similar
suits for older people who find walking
difficult to give them back some freedom
hmx can climb the stairs so it should
get them from their house to their
self-driving car for example the early
versions are adjustable for people
between five five and five ten so I'm a
little too big to fit but H wax fits me
just fine this back hugging robot is
remarkably light at just eight pounds
again with a battery that lasts about
four hours and it's designed to prevent
back injuries in manual Labor's Honda is
far from the only company looking at
exosuits but it thinks that it can use
what it's learning from building smart
and electric cars to get this type of
extension of mobility to market by 2018
so watch your back Tony Stark I'm coming
for you as soon as I move these boxes